at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking - you buy fresh books man oh man
do a lot of listeners in this podcast
and readers of mine love fresh books to
the extent that I ended up meeting with
the CEO not very long ago why are they
so popular well they are the number one
cloud accounting software designed
exclusively for self-employed
professionals that's many of you and
used by more than 10 million people you
can send invoices track your time and
get paid very very quickly which suits
the needs of a lot of freelancers a lot
of entrepreneurs and beyond you can take
pictures of receipts you can link your
credit card and debit cards so all the
things you buy automatically appear in
your fresh books in the right category
so on and so forth makes taxes easy
makes invoices easy makes your life
easier and also in fact I recommend a
PDF they didn't ask me to read this part
by the way they put together PDF a while
back called breaking the time barrier
subtitle how to unlock your true earning
potential so you can search for breaking
the time barrier a lot of people ask me
how can I get a 4-hour work week with a
service business and the story in that
ebook it's PDF is the short answer it's
really really good so I think you should
also check that out so breaking the time
error check it out but also why not test
out fresh books claim your 30-day
unrestricted free trial at fresh
ebooks.com forward slash tim and enter
tim ferriss two hours in two S's in the
how did you hear about us section that
sounds like we're gonna get very little
tracking that's a lot of work but just
go to fresh books comm forward slash tim
and try it out because it is a very good
product and i think you will find it
simplifies your life
enjoy
this episode is brought to you by
Shopify I have known and loved Shopify
just about forever back in 2009 when
they had something like 8 or 10
employees now they have more than 2,000
I helped them as an advisor to create a
build a business competition which is
now the world's largest entrepreneurship
competition and many readers of my blog
first-time business owners have ended up
making millions and millions of dollars
each many of them has side gigs to their
full time jobs so the goal of the build
a business competition is to get
would-be entrepreneurs to get off the
couch and make things happen all you
have to do is open a store on Shopify
and start selling and you can join in
July or after July to be eligible to win
what is winning mean you have to be one
of the top performers top sellers in a
given category and the prize the reward
is an exclusive opportunity to learn
from mentors and experts and in the past
that has happened at places like the
Gatsby Castle where we had Tony Robbins
and Daymond John and Seth Godin and so
on or on Necker Island which is Sir
Richard Branson's private island it's
nuts and super super fun I'm also
involved so there's a special offer for
people listening to this show go to
Shopify dot-com forward slash Tim and
sign up for a free 30-day trial you will
get all sorts of exclusive free video
courses to help you along and to get
started including how to start a
profitable drop shipping business with
Corey Ferreira you will also get some
goodies from me that's all free it's all
exclusive to people who are listening to
this podcast so check it out Shopify
dot-com forward slash Tim and remember
to sign up for the free 30-day trial
why hello there this is tim ferriss team
of adhesive hey you chung breaker of
chains mother of dragons welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
where does my job always to deconstruct
world-class performers of many many
different varieties pulling out the
lesson strategies habits etc that you
can apply and test in your own life my
guest today is none other than the
comedian's comedian bill burr at bill
burr on twitter be I ll be URR please
say hello many of you know him as a
stand-up comedian of course
his YouTube clips have followed me
around the planet as has his podcast he
is one of the funniest humans alive I
mean he loses his audience sometimes on
purpose because making them laugh is not
enough of a challenge and then he'll
wheel them back in and get them back on
his side and he has been requested for
this podcast for many years Rolling
Stone has called him quote the
undisputed heavyweight champ of
rage-fueled humor her end quote and when
we finally got on the same stage to have
a conversation and do this he did not
disappoint so in this very wide-ranging
conversation and bill and I go all over
the place we talk about how he found his
way into stand-up comedy why he enjoys
going for an encore after he's been
booed how he started as a squeaky-clean
comedian and then ended up where he is
now just quite quite different how
learning can serve as therapy the
importance of enjoying success and much
more this interview comes from my TV
show fearless with fear less less in
parentheses because the objective is to
learn to fear less not to be fearless
not possible in which I interview
world-class performers but spry my
favorite combo word on stage about how
they've overcome doubt conquered fear
and made their toughest decisions you
can watch the entire first episode with
illusionist David Blaine for free at
att.net forward slash fearless no
parentheses so all one word ATT net
forward slash fearless the way you would
usually spell it highly recommend you
check that out and to see all episodes
you can get it on DirecTV or
you can go to Direct TV now and I
believe it's just DirecTV now.com Direct
tv.com so dir ICI tv.com and then click
on direct now we recorded about three
hours of material on stage and only one
hour was used for TV that means this
episode is almost entirely new content
that did not appear on TV so even if you
saw that episode already you're gonna
get a lot more patented bill burr so
please enjoy this wide-ranging
conversation with mr. bill burr your
host Tim Ferriss and on this stage will
be deconstructing world-class performers
to uncover the specific tactics so that
they've used to overcome doubt tackle
hard decisions and ultimately succeed so
imagine yourself all alone on stage in
front of 14,000 people staring directly
at you for many of us by most of us
that'd be a complete nightmare but for
my guests tonight it's just another day
at the office the man you're about to
meet is one of the most prolific and
respected comedians in the world he's
done five hour-long comedy specials
hosts one of the most popular podcast of
all time and is the co-creator and star
of the animated series f is for family
please welcome to the stage bill burr
how are you what's going on how you
doing buddy I'm good I'm good
if you ever get food you got to come
back if there's an encore you got to go
back I think we got to go back so I
waved and I remember there was this kid
came running up because I trashed all of
the teams because the Phillies hadn't
won a World Series yet they looked like
two years away from it at that point and
I just remember this kid was like was
was yelling at me was just going he's
giving me the finger yelling [ __ ] you
and I was standing there he was like the
30 yards away I just kept going
give me the finger like I don't know
where it is I just kept going one I
literally got that he was like hopping
mad by the anyone he was jumping up next
to Opie and we would just laugh and go
like how dumb is his kid so but then I
would I was mortified afterwards because
I thought you know cuz I knew like a lot
of stuff was coming up on you know
people were having phones they had
cameras and I was just going you know
everyone's gonna see me get booed this
is gonna be embarrassing I didn't know
how it was gonna play I just thought
that people weren't gonna understand it
The Weavers connected and started
texting because we know Dave Ilic who's
an amazing professional drummer yeah and
teacher yes and teacher is that well he
was a great t-shirt for you guys who are
looking for teachers divided and says
listen more slowly once again something
like that slow down slow down
and I think this Pete order to hate or
do it again on the back and so he'll
just you got sick of saying the same
thing so he just point to one side of
his shirt how did you get into drum it
Wyatt
and why drumming uh how did I get a drum
I guess everyone was into music you know
where I grew up and everything and I
love music and but I didn't start
playing drums I was almost like 20 years
old like I started really late but and
the reason for that was I was working in
a warehouse and I came from a jock town
so everybody played sports you know pond
hockey and all that's why I did a lot of
that stuff and like I liked music but
there's only a couple of kids that play
guitar and I wasn't around it like I
didn't think was possible I thought what
I was watching people doing on TV I just
didn't think he could do it and then I
started working this warehouse and those
kids my age and they were
a different town that was more like kids
put together bands and stuff and they
were coming in like the songs I like
they could play and I was like wow it's
amazing so I started playing guitar and
I just didn't have the patience for it
and I think the thing about drumming was
the sport background where I was like a
real physical thing that it kind of came
into play and I just started I just
started playing and I played for like
six seven years enduring somewhere
during that time I started playing I
started doing stand-up and I moved to
New York and you neighbors don't mind if
your strumming a guitar you can't like
play drums in a one-bedroom apartment
without pissing everybody off so I kind
of stopped for like five years before I
got back into it Long Island I feel like
we have the we don't have a tough accent
that's just a bad accent yeah I think it
was uh it's a lot like the show we do
yeah emphasis of family with where it
was just like the parents just sent you
outside and some days you had good days
sometimes she had bad days sometimes you
just ran into bigger kids and they would
just beat the [ __ ] out of you for no
reason I just think we remember them
putting in a pool one time and they
would just they were like you know
whatever the hell it is when they're
smoothing out the concrete and this
older kid dared me to throw a rock into
it so I wanted his approval and I just
took this big rock and this guy was just
smoothing out I just throw it this guy
almost killed me back when you could
almost kill a kid and it was it wasn't a
problem it was no cell phone video was
all your word against there so I think a
lot of the reasons why I started doing
stand-up was I just thought okay I'm
gonna get on stage show people that I'm
a funny guy and people will stop [ __ ]
with me like that was basically and then
then I was a band that was I remember
thinking that everything's gonna fall
into place I'll meet the girl of my
dreams and make my money I'll get mic
whatever the hell I want a house and so
I only worked on getting better as a
comedian and then by the time I got to
my mid-thirties like being a comedian
was like 600 miles down the road and
everything else was at the starting
blocks and like literally like social
interactions I kept messing up
relationships I mean I was 36 I was
still sleeping sleeping on a futon and
what they
called was a one-bedroom apartment which
was [ __ ] cuz I met the woman who
lived upstairs who have the exact same
apartment and hers was a studio they
just slammed a wall in a mine yeah so I
remembered like those there was like a
three year period of like I was in a
full-on depression and I was so detached
at any I wasn't even I wasn't even aware
of it when what was the age roughly on
that I don't know it was like the early
2000s whatever that may late 90s early
2000s it might have been a five six year
I can't remember I didn't worry about
making it I didn't worry about how am I
gonna make money I didn't worry I just
like I'm doing this and when Billy got
off stage maybe was the end of the night
I was like going like who do I call for
open mics like how do I do this and they
remember he wrote down Rita and I read a
choice who was uh she used to book it
and she was like back then like one of
the big characters like used to always
run into a comedy club so I used to call
in to do open mics and I remember she
used to once she got to know me and she
thought I was kind of funny I'd call up
I'd be like hey hey Rita its Bilborough
I'd like to drive do at Michigan oh no
no no no bill you call me and you say
Rita this is open mic ER bill burr she
was always breaking balls so I would
always laugh and I would do it and she
was kind of like a testy like if you had
like a sense of humor about yourself and
I gradually like worked my way in to
doing stand-up you know I remember one
time I did a show I've told this before
but I did this show I was I was seeing
this woman when I was in New York and
and I member she came over and I was
making her dinner whatever and then I
had a spot at the comic strip which
where I was living was right around the
corner so I said I got to go run do a
spot and during the week I mean you know
she asked me what those spots pay and
they was like commerce it was hilarious
it was like five dollars eight dollars
seven he's basically just going up there
trying out material and I went up there
and I tried out new material and it
worked and I was psyched and I came home
and I finished like cooking the dinner
or whatever they was making I can't read
my was making and I did this stupid
dance in the kitchen and she was
laughing and I was dancing because I had
this no material I was excited and then
she got like this she's got this sad
look on her face my god did I dance that
bad like what's the matter right and she
goes now
gozai I just wish I had a job where I
got paid eight dollars that came home
and danced in a kitchen I don't even
think that cuz I got this weird thing
about money where I I want to have it so
I'm not broke but I don't give a [ __ ]
about it but I also don't want to have
debt so I don't overextend myself but I
don't I don't give a [ __ ] about it like
I will I will pay extra to not go
through the process like I can't even
expect I don't use like you know
frequent flier miles like my wife signed
me up for but I don't use them ever
because I don't want to go through the
[ __ ] you know logging in and all of a
sudden I'm working for American Airlines
and I gotta work for these [ __ ]
people like I'll buy my own ticket I
don't want to do this yeah I won't
cancel [ __ ] like I got like gym
memberships I've never cancelled cuz I'm
not because I'm not going through going
on that stupid thing and if you want to
do this press 1 if you want to do that
press 2 like I got I don't know like my
free time I I cherish it and I'm not
like gonna [ __ ] I'm not I'm not going
to lay on my deathbed one time just
thinking about how many hours I spent on
the phone going person person operator
the person [ __ ] you like I don't want to
do that so I would rather pay the I'd
rather pay the extra charts yeah so a
little bit later I want to pull up the
not caring about money examples that I
have found most personally amusing which
are actually from your podcast so we'll
get to those okay but at the time so if
you just place us when are we working in
your dad's office and maybe you could
describe what your dad did early 90s to
mid 90s I was working in my work in a
dental office and I had been laid off
from the warehouse with the guy all
coked up right but my car was paid off
thank God and I was living at home so I
was kind of living like this little
existence for like three months and my
dad started working with this other guy
went to practice with them and I need he
needed some you know I think we just
sick of watching me being around the
house
so nepotism kicked in and next thing you
know I got a lab coat and I'm standing
next to him to handing him all this [ __ ]
as he's taking teeth out and stuff and I
had to get past the gross factor of that
and then I learned how poor up models
and stuff and takes x-rays and I was
actually I was halfway decent at it but
I knew that you know I for half a second
I thought maybe you know I would do this
but what was funny was I had to call my
father dr. burr I couldn't call him dad
in front of a patient because that would
be weird like hey Dad so I had to keep
it professional and when I worked there
was around the time when I started doing
stand-up and what sucked I was still
living at home so he knew because at the
end of the night he'd be halfway working
tonight and I would have like I'd have
like a gig in Maine living in
Massachusetts and I went for free and I
would drive up there or maybe like five
ten bucks gas money and I would drive
all the way up my dad would have like 7
o'clock patients and [ __ ] like he worked
like a lunatic like from 7 to 7 he would
side book root canals like on molars
which is 3 you know nerve involvement
we'd be--we'd like numb up a guy and
then we go in the other room and like
and he didn't give a [ __ ] - like I one
time some homeless guy came and he was
like I finally got a lunch could you'd
never get a lunch with them this guy
came in you know he was you know
substance abuse and he was all you know
and all these other guys I I noticed
would just give him medicine they would
leave my day I just get him in there and
blah blah I was like pissed now we got
dr. pine what the [ __ ] why can we just
get this guy you know and he just goes
look he goes I can't go home tonight
knowing there's some guy in pain and I
didn't do anything
did you get material for your comedy
from that expert big test I read that
yeah dental comedy early and I don't
know what dental comedy is oh yeah no no
I had all of it oh my dad used to like
he used to set me up because he knew
that I swear to God if I had like a like
a Late Show then he would go extra fast
he'd just go XF give me this give me
that Dino Christ bill you're out to
lunch he would start giving me [ __ ] in
front of the patron I used to tell him
like like dad you can't do that type of
stuff and like he wasn't like that but I
got a lot of it out of like patience
like I remember this guy came in I used
to work totally squeaky clean totally
clean
cuz I didn't want to offend anybody cuz
I didn't want to get heckled because I
was still this really shy person right
so I remember this guy came in one time
and like his teeth were all right now
and I just remember you said something
like like doc you know I don't
understand what the problem is you know
I I brushed my teeth almost every day
right that's it so my punchline to that
was like oh yeah well do you wipe your
ass almost every time you take a [ __ ] so
for a while I started closing on that
joke and I would work totally squeaky
clean going up there looking like Ron
Howard and every like oh this wholesome
guy and then on it nowhere I would just
end with yeah you wiped your ass so much
every time you take a [ __ ] and be like
good night dude what's going on I had no
idea what I was doing I actually was a
prop back for a second where I had one
problem like that's the first whatever
reason you're not allowed to have props
in comedy and acting it's fine I have no
idea right so we had this dental mass
like when you really just had some
gnarly [ __ ] going on they have these
plastic things that look like a welders
shield but was all plastic when just
I'll spare you the details and stuff is
flying at you so I used to bring that
and I would take it out but after I've
do all the dental material and be like
yeah my job so bad like I have to wear
this at work and I would just put it on
and I had no joke and I would put it on
and they'd sort of chuckle and be like
waiting for the joke and then behind the
mats like almost like muffled I'd be
like take it away
and I put it back in my little duffel
bag and I'd walk away it was
I was horrible how do you know when
something is close and when something is
done like yeah when you're working on a
joke or a piece of writing how do you
know when something's done well I think
we're not gonna Turin none of the jokes
are done until I start getting sick of
them then I'm like all right I need to
record these and document these because
they're gonna start becoming not funny
because they're starting to feel like a
job to tell them I'm sick of this joke
and all that god oh and do this joke and
this is one so long and I might not
think that any more and those things
sometimes those things just drop away
and you never record them or anything so
I'd say it's like that when you bombed
that first time is that it Kelly's that
third yeah third gig Jesus you did your
research good team helping me magic
elves in the back as well bees well you
got to cover that camera up on your flat
screen see what you're watching and if
you bang your wife last Tuesday night
when you imagine the drive back after
that gig was very different from from
the Motley Crue they're mortified
mortified how did you what did you do to
get yourself back on the horse for the
vet for the next gig what do you say to
yourself before you got on stage the
next time because a lot of people like
fall off they don't get back on well I
fell off a lot of things they didn't get
back on but like I also always knew I
knew if I was good at something around
5:00 wasn't like you know what I mean
like as much as I loved playing drums
and everything I went to the music store
enough times and saw an eight-year-old
get on a drum kit and I'd be like dude
like I would pay you to take this it's
like I just didn't have it like it's a
hobby it's something I enjoy doing but I
would never subject anybody to it on a
professional level
so this app's me a lot of my ad DS I
went down that road and I forgot the
question which is fine by the way the
question was how did you get back on the
horse would you save yourself before
getting back on well I never did never
dawned
me not to do it again right and you
already are committed to the next gig
all the other social [ __ ] that mortified
me I just stayed away from it and but
that thing was like I don't think I had
another maybe I just was like you Newt
you know what's gonna happen it's like
you're riding a motorcycle you know one
of these days you're gonna go down you
just hope you're gonna live you talked
about some dark periods earlier I'm
forgetting the exact timeline but what
precipitated that I guess you said it
was a couple of years and for people who
don't know
and I almost off myself during a year
off from college so it's like I've had
some some battles my what motive we what
what how are you gonna do it
you know what so this is a good question
and I'll tell you why I'm not gonna give
an answer because it was a really good
plan it was a plan that would minimize
guilt or self blaming on the part of my
family it was really well thought
through I had everything Specht out and
so for the rip line in the woods involve
some porcupines a little bit of cure all
right yeah it was very complex hard to
replicate but yeah I wouldn't want
people to copycat it if I if I put it
out there but how what what precipitated
that period for you um uh what does that
mean what came before then what
triggered it like what legend sorry
using weatherman language my bad I don't
know why comes out of me sometimes yeah
what led what led to it like what
triggers going into that have you
laughing didn't know what it meant
either I just think I was it was that
was just going full speed towards a wall
that yeah you know cuz I thought I was
normal well-adjusted and even though I
knew I had like a crazy temper
I had this period you know where I just
was really just like you know I would be
what you needed me to be yeah and like I
really had like I was friends with
everybody right which is not a real
thing yeah if you're being who you are I
would just I would adjust my
so I wouldn't cause any friction so
there wouldn't be you know any like you
know the [ __ ] I dealt with coming up I
had enough of people screaming and
yelling and enough of fighting and all
that stuff that I would just adjust my
behavior so then we would just be smooth
and I just think using that as a game
plan eventually you're just gonna use so
gonna spin away from who the hell you
are
that I think that you know and also just
focusing on staying up and not other
areas of my life I think then that's
when the the anger and all of that stuff
started to come up and then I kind of
went like this completely different
person and I really started snapping
about nothing for a good twelve years
and uh I think yet somewhere in there
somewhere in there I mean maybe I was
always like depressed but I didn't
realize it I think I just didn't realize
it and somewhere along the line you know
one of the umpteen thousand poor women
that ever came across me like one of
them finally told me to go to therapy
and I went there and thinking like yeah
I'm fine blah blah blah blah blah then
you start telling story and it was all
this [ __ ] that I knew that happened but
was just hovering yeah you just saw it
it's just over here and you're just
going around in life and then all of a
sudden when you start talking about it
it's you say it out loud it's like oh
that's a real thing oh that really did
happen to me it's like and then you
start thinking like wow I'm pretty
[ __ ] up and I'm not happy yeah I'm
really not happy like I really started
getting conscious of what my brain was
telling me and what might if my brain
was like a friend I would like be like
yeah dude we can't do this I mean Jesus
Christ do you ever see the light the
[ __ ] you know so then fortunately I
wasn't like clinically so I didn't need
any medicine all I needed was I just
needed to I just became aware of it then
I'd be like alright well there's that
thought do you want to have that thought
you want to go to the gym I got back
into playing drums which was a great
thing and then they all said I just
stopped giving a [ __ ] about making it
and in a way was just like you know what
[ __ ] forget this I'm just gonna do what
I do because I went through that whole
period like you know I mean many of you
guys trying to make it out here you just
go through that period where you just
like
oh they like guys with you know whatever
blue button-down shirts and he wearing
the blue button-down shirts and people
who talk about this they like in my time
it's gone from the tail end of the sport
coat guy into the grunge guy into the
alt scene into the the whole like
whatever that period was where guys in
their 30s active like they were 14 and
they were awkward and just you know the
hoody like that my wife called um which
you call him not baby men or something
man boys man boys sisters she called him
and I don't know I'm just like awkward
like that was this default thing it's
like oh great now I have to hold up both
ends of the conversation so I really
just those people I really just I kind
of got hostile with they're just like
well when you get over with that you
know and you can [ __ ] talk to me yeah
yeah you are awkward this is weird and I
also thought a lot of people know but a
lot of people that do that it's also
it's a passive-aggressive thing to come
in and [ __ ] steal focus and we all
have to deal with how awkward you are
and make sure you're okay it's like [ __ ]
you dude you're in your 30s figure this
out I never forget one fact I was in a
green room in New York I was living in
LA and I met an old friend and we were
talking about the old days about movie I
remember this guy
remember that night when this happened
we having a great time and there was
younger comics and they were listening
and some people who actually were in the
tail into the stories we have in this
great time and then this this woman
comes in comedian and she was like
socially awkward and she didn't know how
to like get into it so we're all yeah
yeah man we're all laughing everything
and she walked right into the middle of
a circle I swear to god she just
watching on like hello hello hello
and she was like mocking saying hello
yeah but then totally stole all the
focus and everyone's just like oh whoa
you're all right and all the fun went
out of the room and then everyone was
dealing with her and then she left and I
said to my friend go do what what the
[ __ ] was that
I could that was like that was some rude
[ __ ] we were having a great time and
like if you don't know how to say
[ __ ] alone learn how to do it don't
come in and take the whole thing away
and just ruin this thing and that was
the last time that was the last time I
was like [ __ ] these awkward people like
if you're really if you really are I
don't want to like bully people I don't
want to bully something if they really
are socially awkward or something like
that I'll work with you but if you just
embraced right I'm awkward now the world
has to deal with it if that's your [ __ ]
yeah go [ __ ] yourself so we're all we
also have a clip that will pop up in a
minute for amethyst for family that
might I don't know I'll so now that I've
seen all the episodes and now that
you're telling me a lot of these stories
I can see where I think a lot of them
came from there there's one clip that
we'll pull up and in a little bit I'm
not gonna do it just right now
but what have you found to help get you
out of a depressive period you mentioned
exercise for instance I mean I found
drummers in general be very happy people
I don't know if they're happy and then
they end up drumming or if it's because
of the physical aspect of just going
animal on a drum kit it's awesome it's a
great feeling it's I draw I also had
played the drums in college but not very
good at all but that was my experience
it was it was like oh it alleviated a
lot of these darker that's thoughts is
there anything else that you've found
particularly helpful yeah I just do [ __ ]
I just get up and do something that day
and it's literally like I'll I will like
you know I'll go on you like to cook and
stuff so I'll go on YouTube and I'll see
somebody you know what I did recently
who's the guy from Hell's Kitchen I was
going Ramsey yeah Gordon Ramsay dude
he's got this video like the sickest
scrambled egg you're ever gonna make in
your life it's
saying and I just remember watching and
I was just like I'm gonna [ __ ] make
that thing and because I have the free
time like as a comedian like I can do it
I went on I bought all the ingredients
and all that type of stuff and that's
that's what I do and I learn something
[Music]
you know but I do have my hobbies like
cooking and playing drums and a few
other things that I do and it's just
like I I try to have like that moment in
the day like learn something or go
somewhere like and what but working out
is a is a big thing is that's a big
thing how did your goals change if they
did from when you're trying to force fit
yourself like what was the kind of
pinnacle that you had in mind from
making it to after go for me coming up
it was all about having an HBO special
because HBO specials though those were
the best comics that's all the great
guys that I saw coming up you got on HBO
is totally uncensored and they were the
home for that and unfortunately when I
got into it you know writing them like
early 90s by the mid 90s they just
stopped doing it for like ten years
and so I don't that was that's when I
kind of felt rudderless because when HBO
stopped doing their specials I didn't
know what to do and then what what
comedy central's started doing the half
hours they you you are the fact that
they had commercials they basically I
think it's eight minutes each hour so
they were automatically gonna take 16
minutes out or eight minutes out of a
half-hour and then they also they would
they would beep out the curses with like
the worst most archaic like beep beep so
really and they wouldn't just fade it
down and come back up
so I remember watching specials and just
thinking that was really distracting so
once again I work clean so if you watch
my first half-hour comedy central I work
totally clean
and I gave them I gave them the least
amount of material that I could because
I just looked at it because those guys
doing like our here's a half you know
what it's a half hour they're only gonna
use 22 minutes they what they would do
is they'd do 40 so then you had this guy
who you didn't know you didn't approve
of is now going to hack
40 minutes down to 22 what is he gonna
do exactly so I was like I mean I was
like wow [ __ ] that
what what's the least you can do and
they said least you can mount of time
you can do is like 25 or 26 and I did
exactly that so the worst you could do
was butcher for of it out but the rest
of it was gonna look good so I was happy
with it and you know I was just kind of
doing stuff like that but that it still
wasn't what I wanted because it wasn't
me that that half hour that I did that
was me like just kind of doing an
extended Letterman spot where I was
working totally clean and but it wasn't
until HBO came back and did the half
hours and I did those that I actually
got to do it was the first time people
got to see me you know not in a club
they we're at home and they got to see
that this is what I do and it you know
and that was the same time I got on the
Opie and Anthony show and they all kind
of came out at the same time was the
first time I went to a club and it was
sold out and people were there to see me
which was a whole other level of
pressure hust it used to be yes up until
then it was people coming to the club
because that's what they did they had
nothing else to do like let's get on the
comedy club and you had to prove to them
that you were funny and I used to member
think I'll imagine they came to see me
how much easier this would be and I
didn't realize the other pressure was
like no we saw that so we're expecting
at least that if not better and then
it's like oh man so that took me like a
good three months of the there was a new
kind of nervousness experience to get
over of people expecting like yeah we're
here to see you we like what you do
don't ruin this what was the first
special the first half-hour yeah or not
the Comedy Central but the first time
you could be yourself oh that was the
HBO half-hour that I did and that was in
2005 2005 still remember April 2005 came
out in September has is there anything
since then and out then and this is an
assumption of my part which is dangerous
but do you feel like you had summited
the mountain at that point do you feel
like you'd arrived no I felt that
somewhere in like 2009 2010 by then I'd
done a couple of hours
second hour for Netflix which became the
new HBO as far as just totally
uncensored and I'm I think I bought a
house at that point I bought a house
right and still you know people didn't
really nice following in that and I said
to my wife I was just like I know you're
not supposed to say this but I made it
because there's a sickness in this
business of like no man if you think you
made it and then you're gonna relax and
it's all gonna go away so like oh so I'm
never gonna be happy yeah it's like I
tell dick jokes and I just bought a
house I made it I don't want to be that
guy that that is doing well I was like
oh but what about the next thing like
those DUHS that that sickness just the
greyhound chasing there at the rain yeah
performance or driven people can have
this sickness of like it's just you know
it's just like you can't even enjoy it's
like what's the next thing I mean I know
guys that like they have like they
accomplished something and as they're
right as they're getting right to the
peak this depression hits them cuz
they're like then what and then what am
I gonna do and then this is over and
then then I got nothing and blah blah
blah it's like hey can you just [ __ ]
have a beer up here we did this can we
enjoy this for a second
did you keep did you continue doing
therapy after those initial sessions
yeah I did it for a few years and then
one day I just dawned on me that I just
kind of I'm just talking in circles in
here and it's just like bad shits gonna
always happen to me
and what am I gonna keep coming in here
I'm moaning about it like at what point
am I gonna grow up and kind of not need
not need this and I'm not trying to say
that you week if you go there but I I
just hit this point where I was I was
like I you know I all of that [ __ ]
happened you know it happened right and
it definitely affected Who I am
but now I'm not gonna be like lashing
out of people and I'll be like oh I do
this because of that a little a little
bit of that but I what I did you know at
some point you'd be like if somebody's
teaching how to fix a car at some point
you got to try to fix it yourself you
know II can't keep going in oh I turn
right here how do I do this right so I
just became like that so now I kind of
you know my kind of self therapy myself
it's cheaper yeah you mentioned the I
guess delusion maybe of always chasing
the next thing and never being satisfied
with where you are the other worry that
I've heard a lot from friends of mine
who are comedians is that if they do
therapy or meditation or fill in the
blank to tone down some of their
tendencies that it will make them less
funny yeah
is that something you I thought that was
true enough it's not true bored it does
is it gives you an insight into you as a
human and then you start you see people
differently and it actually allowed me
to write like or think about characters
and just notice [ __ ] with people that I
never did before like I got a I got a
thing with somebody who somebody anybody
who does this when they're talking like
I was about they're full of [ __ ] not
only not only are they full of [ __ ] and
a complete inability to accept
responsibility for anything they've ever
done
I just recently told this to Jim Norton
it was that publicist who backed over
like those 12 people in like Long Island
oh sure and then I remember she just she
drove away and then she went to her
house and when she got to her house like
the cops showed up and the lawyer met
them in the driveway and was like yeah
she'll come down tomorrow and blah blah
blah and they left and I remember
thinking like you can [ __ ] do that
I don't know you could do that so she
was of course vilified and then the next
day in the paper they had this picture
of her and she was like talking to the
meters using your hands like [ __ ]
back over 11 people I'll go with you
that that can happen that you can't see
that but you left you [ __ ] left yeah
get the [ __ ] out of here so I've noticed
that and I remember so you start picking
up on that and I remember one time this
comic did some passive-aggressive [ __ ]
to him I call D'Amato and he immediately
went with the two hands to the chest I'm
like that's kind of guy that went back
over 11 people drive away so I wouldn't
have noticed that if I didn't go to
therapy and I've also noticed like
you know like I like yeah I talked to
myself a lot about like oh and you know
like getting into it with people and
screaming and yelling and then I'll
drive away and be like guy bill how did
that go you know and then try to see how
they're how you know if I was wrong in
it like they were right you know
that's somebody's mom you just yelled at
her like what's wrong with you you're
like I really had like a like really a
hair-trigger kind of thing so it's
something that you know working on my
temper I really try to I've really been
like especially lately because you know
I was making my wife like on pins and
needles because it wasn't like I was
flipping out over anything like I
[ __ ] hate these things
whatever this the second I came out and
I saw this do whatever this is this pad
yeah I bet
I hate these by 86 I can't stand them
they don't make my life easier if
they're a nightmare they're intrusive
you know and my I can't stand it's life
I flip out about him in like I saw I
think recently this politically active
comedian was sitting there talking abou
trying to get people to vote and like
this oddly like bullying way going like
you know there's gonna be an app out
there that's gonna say you know whether
you vote it or not and they're not gonna
know whether you vote it and who you
voted for but they're gonna know that
you voted so you can't basically
[ __ ] people anymore
I just was watching the whole time going
and like that's a good thing that that
level of private information because of
this [ __ ] app I didn't say you could
say what I voted or not that's what I
that's what I I hate above all of this
[ __ ] like I I have a theory like like
somewhere around 94 95 we should we
should have stopped making new [ __ ]
alright they could they cured enough
diseases cars were fast enough you could
get you know planes aren't anything
really faster than they were back then
it was good but all of this [ __ ] now
that like you know tape your cameras
yeah tape your camera stuff look at
Billy Bush Billy Bush got fired for some
[ __ ] that happened in 2005 it's [ __ ]
unbelievable and all he was doing is
what an interviewer does he was keeping
the interviewee happy right the guy glad
just grab the [ __ ] as I grab some [ __ ]
whatever we doing this
before all you know at the end of the
interview when Trump left he could have
been like what was that how was that guy
like I think I was out of his mind my
grab and [ __ ] he's [ __ ] crazy
anyways who do we got next Matthew
McConaughey just doing that for all you
know that's all he was doing it was
literally like that's what I hate about
this [ __ ] it's like you'd literally take
two seconds to somebody's [ __ ] life
and you're like that's who you are
that's you what that that tweet is who
you are that's what's in your heart and
all of this [ __ ] I got friends of mine
they've gotten like Big Show's SNL and
stuff like that I think the one person
they had to go back to 2010 they went
through six years of tweets to try and
for what was about this one hey yeah
it's I get the [ __ ] out of here right
why didn't you start doing the podcast I
guess a Bobby Kelly once again I was
hanging in his apartment when we used to
live near each other in New York and he
was just like dude you gotta do this
it's called a podcast I had no idea what
it was you can think you know it's
another way to connect with your fans
and both me and him in all of my friends
we weren't the guys they were pickin
yeah we just weren't the guys we weren't
whatever they were going for it they we
just never were the guys and you know
and yet we they went on every showcase
they'd always put us on last because we
would you know we were really good at
what we did but there was always like
the you know whatever the hell it was
they were looking for we were just we
were the outcasts so so anyway to
connect with your fans we had to do it
and that was this new thing and I just
like doing it at first I just I used to
call in he used to think before I had
like the mixer and all that used to
calling this this service so I would
just call up this phone number on my
flip phone and I would just let me be in
airports and I would just be trashing
people and telling stories and singing
songs and at first I just did it for
like seven minutes and it was ten
minutes then it became twenty than a
half hour and then I started going like
well you know yeah you know ask me some
questions or I had this thing underrated
overrated for a while and YouTube video
of the week and I just sort of built
like a show around it and and it just
kind of became what it became was it for
shits and giggles or was there something
no I wanted to connect with fans you
know it was a way to just just another
thing to do and but it was also I
enjoyed it
because there's other ways to connect
with fans that I don't enjoy like all
those those things you guys when you
upload your pictures I don't like those
because it says can we have access to
all your photos and it's like no you can
have access to this photo you [ __ ]
weirdo so I don't do it you know so I
just don't do any of those but then
there's other stuff that it's the same
thing it's like the mall thing again
like does this fit into the wheelhouse
of what I feel like I want to do it was
just something I like doing so I just
started doing it so between or I should
say during the period of your specials
and then getting all the way to at this
your family what were the what were the
high points for you in that that entire
question I just heard that person
groaning out there like sorry sorry
that's a c- question bear with me no I
think I'm working on my material
I think it's ass is hurting from sitting
down so so from the from the point that
you started doing your specials up to
afters her family were there any
particular inflection points or
experiences that set you on the path
that led you to where you are ah that
formative experience is you don't think
of Chappelle's Show
Breaking Bad I mean you you have so much
that you've done I'm just wondering if
any standout like influenced my comedy
or it just got me to where I'm at both
either all right well getting me to
where I'm at is like you know how long
it took me to make it is like it's a
bunch of people it's comics that I saw
when I was in Boston people who gave me
shots getting in at the comic strip was
woman Amanda Schatz at MTV she saw me in
Boston and then she's like I want you to
I want to see you in New York and I
couldn't get in at the comic strip I'm
involution going I already have enough
white guys well blah blah blah blah blah
I remember I remember all these white
guys used to get mad if I reverse racism
boom they want to say all this type of
[ __ ] it's just like dude you know what
he's saying there's like we're not even
a dime-a-dozen there's like we're a dime
460 of us and if you're gonna be another
asphalt coming in here talking about
your cul-de-sac life
he already has that so you know stop
being a baby
right everything else is gravy for you
as a white dude so so I guess basically
was like I remember thinking like I this
guy so I'm gonna get in here I don't
know how but I'm gonna get in here and
she saw me and so she hooked me up with
the showcase there somehow I did well I
got past there which led me to get into
New York and then through New York just
be in there I remember Dave Chappelle
said some nice things to me one night
saying that basically you're gonna get
there but the road that you're going is
gonna take longer but when you when you
get there you're gonna have that staying
thing and I held onto that for years and
when I would be playing some [ __ ] I
was just like but Dave Chappelle said
yeah but then it was just you know a lot
of radio guys Jim Norton get me in with
open and he was huge
Randy Bauman in Pittsburgh because like
I would go to these markets and the guys
that I really vibe with like they would
give me the option to be like hey rather
than flying in Thursday morning for your
Thursday through Sunday if you want to
fly in Wednesday or Tuesday and just do
radio the whole week you know I'll help
you pack the place and guys like Randy
bombing in Pittsburgh and I would do
that I would just come in have no shows
Tuesday Wednesday and I would just do
four hours of radio in the morning do
the whole morning show and then do
morning on Thursday and Friday just
killing as hard as I could to you know
get it like half fold maybe they don't
have to pull the curtain and it was just
all those types of things and I guess I
don't have been doing this [ __ ] for a
long time so try yeah Breaking Bad
Breaking Bad was huge because forever I
wanted to play a guy like that all right
but back when I had my hair and stuff I
look like Ron Howard so it was like day
I was always the friend I was the nerd I
just wasn't gonna be that guy and I just
always wanted to play a guy like Kuby
and they gave me a shot and and then
through that all of a sudden I got these
other roles like you know once you get
it on tape and they can see that you can
do it then like oh we can do this and
then people will take a shot on you so
that that was a huge thing
I'd say Mike binder with when I did
black or white which became black and
white black yeah it was what was it it
was a black and white was the original
name of it but somebody already owned
the copyright of that and they wouldn't
sell its then we had to switch it to
black or white and it was like this
trial about who should have the the
rights to watch this kid that was was
racially mixed was half white and half
black so black and white made it seem
inclusive but we had to switch it to
black or white so kind of became like
this make a decision kind of fight but
he let me I got to play a lawyer in that
and I had all these great dramatic
scenes and all that so I kind of got a
nice like acting thing going on where I
get to do some drama stuff I get to do
some comedy stuff so it's been cool yeah
[Applause]
speaking of Cosmo magazine this next
question is from Marcus horrible I think
as I said also from Facebook my wife
thinks he's hilarious and she's
generally not a fan of Pro mail types of
comedy how did he learn to so expertly
deliver that kind of humor without
alienating his female audience highly
innate a lot of females I do I a lien 8
issue people I a lien 8 politically
correct people like to think they got
like that thing we're like you know this
is the issue you're only allowed to have
this thought on this issue I have zero
sense of humor about this issue these
are all the proper words these are all
the but if you use these bed we've used
these words this your this if you use
that they're very like it's hilarious
because they're progressive left using
the exact same like Fox News extreme
right they're the exact same [ __ ]
lunatics I hate him but I hate
progressive left people and I generally
speaking and the Fox News to the right
they're taking our country those people
those I can't even listen to him they're
idiots
they're like both of them and they both
have
both of them like like their heart is in
the right place they just they're not
doing it that and they're doing it in
this very Stalinist kind of way of zero
tolerance yeah and what's funny to me is
the right always gets that the left just
cannot see when they're doing it it's
like you've become what the [ __ ] you're
fighting and you're annoying
yeah you're annoying so I mean I think
that explains you know a little bit of
the Trump [ __ ] like how that guy kind of
came up with it's like you guys were
ramming this [ __ ] down like what this is
just so [ __ ] up if you just look at
politics like Obama was a response to
eight years of the bush people ramming
it down your throat and he was a
response to eight years of Clinton
people ramming it down their throats and
then twelve years before that you had
Reagan and Bush both sides just can't
present this [ __ ] they're gonna be like
[ __ ] you know and it's all it does is
it it causes resentment and that if you
look the pendulum just keep swinging
like further and further and people
sound [ __ ] right now people sound
crazy to me on either side that I can't
watch it it's like if anybody if anybody
in the left gets in it's like it's gonna
be socialism this is going to be like
communist Russia and if anybody right
gets in it's like this is like Germany
in 1935 every [ __ ] time just just go
and just go in like this so I don't know
like I just try to just be like all
right just let's settle down everybody
[ __ ] relax get yourself a sandwich
some of these things could be true some
of them might not be true but like
getting into this you're not gonna be
able to think clearly and be able to
make the right move when you have to III
guess so what was sick now do you
deliberately at times try to lose the
audience like push them to the breaking
point
and like there is something that I and
then reel them back I mean is that what
do you what I used to do that was from
playing hell rooms and no one would
listen so what I would do is I would
make a statement that would make people
be like dude what the [ __ ] and thinking
that I'm heading towards
this thing right like I would make a
statement that would make anything make
you feel like I'm heading towards like
supporting the Klan or beating women or
anything like that you just say that and
that gets everybody to drop their fork
to listen so like do what the [ __ ] is
this and then you just wind them back to
the point that you wanted to make anyway
you just keep doing that and then
eventually once I once I had the room
yeah once I had the room then I could
just do my show and I think a little bit
of that started to bleed into my style I
don't I mean I don't do that anymore on
purpose when I was coming up I used to
do that on purpose there was all these
techniques you could also start talking
quieter if people are talking louder
people used to say that that never
[ __ ] worked for me then oh just
nobody heard me I'm just like okay
nobody's listening to my jokes but you
know yeah a lot of that came from you
know all the those crazy rooms I did and
I'm very proud that I did all those and
I didn't sidestep any of those like I
pretty much did all of them I did the
the good rooms the bad rooms the white
rooms black rooms gay clubs I did
everything cuz I I really felt that I I
know why I know why I just remember this
I when I was a kid not a kid I was like
probably eighteen years old and it was
the summer of 86 and Rodney Dangerfield
late great Rodney Dangerfield was on he
was on tour and he came to this place
great woods now it's called the tweeter
center and I remember he came and he
killed he was hilarious and all that and
I saw all these people there bla bla bla
bla bla and I didn't notice that they
were all white cuz that was white so I
was just like wow I watching this guy
whatever and then like like a month
later I saw Eddie Murphy on the rot or
he had the blue leather suit I lawn
seats that's how famous this dude was I
was sitting in on the grass watch it guy
doing stand-up comedy had like the
weather girls opened up for him and
everything and I remember that night
looking around going wait this guy's
making everybody laugh this is the
difference so I remembered when I'm
getting into comedy that I didn't want
to be that guy like being like a radio
station like he makes white males 18 to
35 you know like I wanted to be like now
this guy is funny but
the only way to do that was to do all of
those those different rooms and it
didn't it didn't always go well like
black rooms of hilarious like they it's
like the door I learned about them is
they're either gonna having fun no Matt
they're gonna have fun with you or
without Luke but either way they're
gonna have a good time so that was
definitely those were some of my
favorite shows that I ever did there was
that there was a legendary show at this
now gone comedy club that sound like a
[ __ ] wine bar which just kills me cuz
I mean it was just the Rost sickest like
in the village he was right as Giuliani
was taking over some people who still
selling drugs out in front of him it was
just it was crazy and I used to see like
you know all these guys like young Dave
Chappelle Jay Mohr all these red Johnny
around guy all these guys to Steve just
murdering in there but Sunday night was
was the Uptown show because they
wouldn't say you know the black only
show I guess so they would say the
Uptown show and this guy talent in and
will sylvans he used to host that show
and that for me that was the show like
to this day like that was that was the
most fun show I ever did was when when
you killed on that show dude it was like
you walked out of like why am I not
famous yet like that's how hard it was
just everyone was on top you it was the
greatest ever but when you bombed it was
just like why did I ever think I was
funny I should have opened a hardware
store like I would just leave like the
jet those are some rough nights though
going back to the technically one
bedroom that was really a studio and
getting onto the futon just laying there
yeah a lot of grunt and groan in the
next day in the shower like what piece
of advice would you give your 25 year
old self I hate that question
why are we saying if you could go back
and tell yourself what's you know now
what did you dislike about your 25 year
old self if you prefer that question um
[Music]
what did I dislike no I definitely felt
like a freak back then I definitely did
not feel I never felt like I fit in
anywhere until I went to a comedy club
and just seeing all the comics then I
was just like these these people are the
same kind of crazy than I am you know
what I mean like everybody's out of
their mind but like they there was a
specific way that they were nuts that
like I just felt like yeah we just meet
him like it's like I know this person
but I don't know them like they it just
felt like in a weird way like you were
going home it was crazy but as far as
like what I would tell myself I would be
afraid to [ __ ] it up because it ended up
so well yeah you know it's like that
back to the school and I put back to the
future whatever the hell it's called I
always mess up the name of movies Back
to the Future where you change one thing
your mom wants to [ __ ] you however that
[Laughter]
movie the mom wants to bang her son from
the future oh it's great for the kids it
was wonderful how old you know 48 what
do you think your 60 year old self would
tell your current self try some
apartment buildings buy some apartment
oh yes because you're gonna be you know
iknow I want to do stuff like that
because I want to when I'm 70 I want to
leave if I want to I probably won't
because I love doing it so much but I
don't want to be that guy in that
mustard-stained tuxedo suit just still
you know as the numbers start going down
the back nine people going like oh I saw
I'm in front of like three people it was
sad
there was a doughnut making sheet
machine in the back I'd go back to those
gigs so I would like to not go out and
you know I'm doing real well I'm making
great money I would like to not go out
and buy a bunch of dumb shine
[ __ ] I would like to buy [ __ ] like
assets so I have money so my next goal
the same way I did the thing where I
never got sucked so far into this
business where I had to apologize if I
wasn't even if I wasn't sorry I I now
want to get the money that making this
business to make money outside of the
business so cuz eventually this business
is done with you yeah it just is and you
have to relate you got to deal with that
[ __ ] so like I I would just love to be
to be honest with you man if I could
just you know making a decent amount of
money off of [ __ ] like that yeah I just
always picture myself just sitting on
the back porch you know with a dog not
giving a [ __ ] smoking a cigar like
that's how I want to what kind of we
still do stuff oh they don't mess him up
with global warming if he can still make
a great want to definitely be a Cuban
probably a reboost oh the Cohibas I like
I like the Partagas I just smoked one
recently I know the name of it was one
of the sickest cigars I I've ever smoked
but it was like it was like a two-hour
smoke and I I absolutely love cigars but
like you know there is a thing amongst
cigar smokers where like if someone
comes nosing around you know if you
break up you bust out like a box of
cigars at a party all these [ __ ]
phonies will come up oh yeah oh you
smoke cigars and you'll learn this one
time you'll give out you get cigars to
him and then what kills you is you'll
look over like a half hour later and the
things like halfway smoked and they
already ash the thing out is no snub the
thing out and I learned that so I got a
buddy Bobby Kelly I shouldn't out him
here I should have said his name yes sir
he has cigs in most he has two humidors
he's got the real [ __ ] and then he's got
his [ __ ] so if somebody comes over
be like so he just yeah you like cigars
oh yeah what kind what kind of you like
it if they just saying [ __ ] I I got
one for you
I got one I wanted a carnival so I
really like smoking a cigar is is a
sacred thing to me like if I have a
great cigar like sometimes if there's no
place to smoke I will not smoke it like
I'm not gonna be this [ __ ] these [ __ ]
and a couple of my friends they're
animals they'll stand next to a dumpster
like it's not a cigarette smokers are
animals they're like they're on the [ __ ]
right so they'll be in an alley they
care [ __ ] rat running by they're out
there smoking catching pneumonia they're
animals
cigar smoking is a gentleman thing it's
like it so it's um brilliance an adult
thing and so it's just like I want to be
with people that I love telling stories
hanging out and like the right the right
everything and and then and even if
you're doing it by yourself it's like
you have to have I'm never doing this
like well can I can i smoke it before
blah blah blah it's like I would just
want to have nothing and I just sit
there and that great guy thing that my
wife cannot understand is just being
able to be a guy and just be not
thinking about [ __ ] and just be sitting
there next questions from sharp e sharp
I would like to see that birth
certificate this is from Facebook what's
the best heckle that's been thrown your
way or most memorable there's too many
men all right we'll go around we'll go
around the alright when I was black room
best one I ever got I was bombing at
this place used to be called mixed nuts
it's now called the comedy Union and I
was up there and do when I tell you five
minutes of straight silence dry mouth
nothing and it was the summer time when
sound carries right and I am just going
and going and there's nothing and
nothing and then just in the middle of
one of my jokes a meandering and this
long set up for something else that's
gonna bomb it's big black lady in the
back just out loud to nobody just sort
of looked around this way
and the whole place exploded laughing I
[Applause]
didn't know how to deal with it I didn't
know I had to address it I kept trying
to do my material and then they were
just laughing at me trying to do man it
was a [ __ ] humiliating and then I
don't know there's one I'll take the
weirdest one I got I told this one
before when the weirdest ones I got I
was a Dangerfield in doing the midnight
show and it was just
one of those nights everyone who was
bombing in place was packed and nobody
was laughing I remember the guy in front
of me like he was just bombing so bad
and he was in on some show where he
played a bartender and he had gotten
beaten up it's like oh you guys see that
movie he's trying it you guys see this
movie bla bla bla bla he goes yeah I
played the bartender the you know the
star of the movie beat the [ __ ] you know
beat the [ __ ] out of me you guys see
that and then some kid in the back just
goes he should have killed you so I was
like oh and that guy walked past me
never even looked at me he just when he
got off stage he just said this flop
split and just walked by me just going
wow wow and then I went on stage
immediately bombing and there was this
group of kids in the corner these white
dudes and they were just like just ready
for a fight they were just super [ __ ]
on there that whole my dad used to beat
the [ __ ] out of me vibe yeah and
everything I had learned up into that
point was like bill don't get into it
with them I heard him talking and I was
just don't say anything don't say
anything and then finally I just it's
this [ __ ] thing when you're on stage
as a comic you think like this and this
is like some sort of like a [ __ ] gun
and bullets but it isn't it's just
plastic [ __ ] and I just like I finally
said it going you know what what's going
on over there what are you guys talking
about
blah blah blah I can't men what st. and
this guy just finally was just yelled
out you know I had the he goes anything
cuz yells out he goes anything red and
on stage is a [ __ ]
right and it was the most childish
heckle I ever got this back when like
people didn't freak out about that word
you guys like oh my god what does that
say about gay people this was when
straight people used it it just meant
you were an [ __ ] and so he said that
I just remembered like I didn't know
what to do was just like it was so
[ __ ] childish but I also know he was
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of me so I just
went like right back into my state mic
my act like there's almost like a
cooties joke hey you know this right
here the reaction to that is why you can
never leave the comedy clubs by the way
like because that used to be a funny
story but now because of like that gay
people said what that word makes us feel
like now everybody even if you say it
and you say that somebody else said it
to you it becomes this weird thing of
like
well does he advocate what he said
republic just becomes all of that and
becomes like context and all of that
[ __ ] so well that's what he said spend a
few handful more questions you mentioned
helicopter parents helicopters
helicopters yes let's talk about
helicopters all right how did you how
and why didn't you get into Telugu yeah
you just running the gamut of everything
here
oh yeah helicopters how do I get into
that paranoia of living in California
okay living in the LA basin enough
conspiracy theory about nothing being
behind the dollar robots coming and all
that type of [ __ ] and this this place
became really claustrophobic I was just
like how the hell would I ever get out
of here
when this [ __ ] hits the fan how do you
get out of here like even when it's
working well it still takes three hours
just to get out of here forget about
some Armageddon's [ __ ] and I would just
thought you know up and out that's the
way to go learn how to fly a helicopter
and when the zombies come you just start
it up and just fly out assuming you're
by the way that does not work if you
ever see that in the movies will you
just start the thing up and you fly it
like that I mean you can do that but
you're gonna [ __ ] it up like you got to
let the band the band that they got like
belts and stuff you got to let those
things stretch you got to let the engine
heat up and all that so anytime you see
Rambo and those guys just jumping in and
cold likes to Camaro and you just I mean
if zombies were coming I would
definitely do that [ __ ] but I'd be going
please don't let the belt snap then you
just knows it down and don't one of
those [ __ ] take one with you just
imagining the visual ah just like a lawn
mower just taking out zombies they said
do you have other preparations now this
is spoken to someone so people think
this is crazy
so in San Francisco and then in New York
got really into at one point went off
the deep end with prepping stuff I got
really into it like going to canneries
for LDS you guys can look it up you can
really go down the rabbit hole and some
of you will spin out and get tied up in
a straitjacket but I and I
was being kind of lectured at how
unreasonable it was now silly was that I
was getting water and gathering food and
all this stuff just in case we had
disasters took us off the grid for seven
days or more SF which happens fairly
regularly and some editors were kind of
making fun of me I was writing at the
time and then hurricane sandy hit New
York and lo and behold nobody was
prepared right so do you have besides
the helicopter
do you have other preparations nope no
and I don't own a helicopter either so
it's pretty [ __ ] useless know what it
was was I went down that rabbit hole and
you got to get gold coins and you got to
get this powdered food and all that type
of stuff and then somewhere along the
line I was just like do I really want to
survive this do I really want to see
what's next or do I want to be one of
the people that dies like then I realize
now I want to be one of the people that
died JFK said it the the the the the
living will envy the dead and it's true
I don't want to start over again some
whole new society I remember doing a
face to bid on that so we just picking
up a rake like these are the new rules
and you just solve gathering around with
your burlap shirt with the string tied
around it I don't like I remember when
that fat dude who's run in North Korea
right the boss's son who's way too hard
yeah to show that he's a badass was
saying he was gonna he had missiles
aimed at LA and everyone was panicking I
was like perfect man I hope it's right
at my house right in my house and I hope
I'm watching the UFC or football Sunday
to sit nip who you don't want to be is
the people up in Bakersfield just
outside of it but you still get the
radiation with the boils and [ __ ] you're
trying to your teeth are falling out
[ __ ] that try to figure out how to catch
squirrels they have no desire to do any
of that
[Applause]
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
episode is brought to you by Shopify I
have known and loved Shopify just about
forever back in 2009 when they had
something like eight or ten employees
now they have more than two thousand I
helped them as an advisor to create
build a business competition which is
now the world's largest entrepreneurship
competition and many readers of my blog
first time business owners have ended up
making millions and millions of dollars
each many of them has side gigs to their
full-time jobs so the goal of the build
a business competition is to get
would-be entrepreneurs to get off the
couch and make things happen all you
have to do is open a store on Shopify
and start selling and you can join in
July or after July to be eligible to win
what is winning me you have to be one of
the top performers top sellers in a
given category and the prize the reward
is an exclusive opportunity to learn
from mentors and experts
in the past that has happened at places
like the Gatsby Castle where we had Tony
Robbins and
David John and Seth Godin and so on or a
new Necker Island which is Sir Richard
Branson's private island it's nuts and
super super fun I'm also involved so
there's a special offer for people
listening to the show go to Shopify
dot-com poet slash tim and sign up for a
free 30-day trial you will get all sorts
of exclusive free video courses to help
you along and to get started including
how to start a profitable drop shipping
business with Cory Ferreira you will
also get some goodies from me it's all
free it's all exclusive people who are
listening to this podcast so check it
out Shopify dot-com forward slash PIM
and remember to sign up a free 30-day
trial this episode is brought to you by
fresh books man oh man do a lot of
listeners of this podcast and readers of
mine love fresh books to the extent that
I ended up meeting with the CEO not very
long ago why are they so popular well
they are the number one cloud accounting
software designed exclusively for
self-employed professionals that's many
of you and used by more than 10 million
people you can send invoices track your
time and get paid very very quickly
which suits the needs of a lot of
freelancers a lot of my friend of Lowe's
and beyond you can take pictures of
receipts you can link your credit cards
and debit cards so all the things you
buy automatically appear in your fresh
books in the right category so on and so
forth makes taxes easy makes invoices
easy makes your life easier and also in
fact I recommend a PDF they didn't ask
me to read this part by the way they put
any other PDF a while back called
breaking the time barrier subtitle how
to unlock your true earning potential so
you can search for breaking the time
barrier a lot of people ask me how can I
get a 4-hour workweek with the service
business and the story in that ebook its
PDF is the short answer it's really
really good so I think you should also
check that out so breaking the time
error check it out but also why not test
out fresh books claim your 30-day
unrestricted free trial at fresh
ebooks.com forward slash tim and enter
tim ferriss two hours and two S's in the
how did you hear about us section that
sounds
like we're gonna get very little
tracking that's a lot of work but just
go to FreshBooks comm forward slash Tim
and try it out because it is a very good
product and I think you will find it
simplifies your life enjoy
[Applause]